good evening my name is Austin Gorgons
and I'm a sophomore here at Hillsdale
College currently I'm studying English
and psychology and tonight it's my
pleasure to introduce to you a speaker
mr. Byron York is chief political
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner and Fox News contributor he
earned his Bachelors of Arts from the
University of Alabama as master's degree
from the University of Chicago mr. York
has covered the bush-obama and Trump
administrations as well as Congress and
each presidential campaign since the
year 2000
formerly White House correspondent for
National Review he's written for
numerous publications including The Wall
Street Journal the Washington Post
Atlantic Monthly foreign affairs and the
New Republic mr. York is a regular guest
on television including Meet the Press
PBS Newshour and the Laura Ingraham show
he is the author of the vast left-wing
conspiracy and an account of liberal
activism in the 2004 election please
join me in welcoming mr. Byron York
[Applause]
thank you very much and thank you for
mentioning my contributions to the
Atlantic Monthly I'm very proud of that
than a few years thank you for very much
for having me tonight I was I was
delighted to come to Hillsdale I I I
gave a speech at a Hillsdale event in
Chicago a few years ago and I went to a
on a cruise a couple of years ago that
was just fantastic but I've never
actually been to Hillsdale and it's just
a real pleasure to come to this
beautiful beautiful place and I was
delighted to be asked to discuss
political scandals
now it says political scandal since 2008
and one of the guests came up to me
before dinner and said you are gonna
talk about Bill Clinton aren't you and I
said don't you worry I will so we're
gonna we're gonna go back a little
farther than 2008 because I do think
that going back 20 years instead of ten
will tell us a lot about today's
political battles I almost view Bill
Clinton and Donald Trump has kind of
bookends of presidential scandals if you
if you look at the Clinton years I mean
there were a lot of scandals and I loved
every one of them but the two really big
ones were a sex scandal and a foreign
influence scandal we hear a lot about
more than about one than the other and
now Trump is dealing with a foreign
influence scandal and the beginnings of
a sex scandal as well so I'm gonna talk
about those and what the different ways
in which they were treated may tell us
but first I need to say a couple of
things about the old Independent Counsel
law because that played a big role in
those Clinton scandals now you learned a
lot about it today from Professor Marini
this was a post watergate reform the
Ethics in Government Act 1978
essentially creates a special
Independent Counsel who's like a fourth
branch of government essentially serves
as the research arm of the House
Judiciary Committee when it wants to
impeach a president now Republicans were
really burned by this law in the 1980s
with the independent with the
iran-contra affair there was an
independent counsel his name was
Lawrence Walsh
he was extremely political he stretched
out his investigation to last forever as
a matter of fact the first story I ever
wrote for the Wall Street Journal
editorial page must have been about nine
three and I learned that Lawrence Walsh
was still coming to Washington every
week and checking into the Watergate
Hotel which is about the most expensive
hotel in Washington and staying in
luxury while he still investigated the
iran-contra scandal and Ronald Reagan
was gone from office and George HW Bush
was gone from office and he was still
doing it I think the title was the final
paydays of Lawrence Walsh but he just
went on forever so when the law expired
in the early 90s Republicans said let it
die it's bad it is bad news let it die
but the Democrats who apparently thought
that this law just existed to target
Republicans said no no no we must we
must extend this law and they said it in
a very self-righteous way Bill Clinton
himself called the Independent Counsel
law quote a foundation stone for the
trust between the government and our
citizens a force for government
integrity and public confidence and so I
will say knowing what happened after
that it is okay to laugh when you hear
what he said because the Independent
Counsel law rose up and repeatedly bit
him on the backside there were just tons
of independent counsels during his time
in office by the time he finished there
were seven most of them are totally
forgotten today do you remember Donald
Smaltz I didn't either he was appointed
to look into mike espy's conduct as the
Secretary of Agriculture totally
forgotten
you remember David Barrett totally
forgotten he was to look into whether
Henry Cisneros who was the housing
secretary paid off his mistress so there
were these seven independent council
vesting investigations and at the top of
the pyramid his count star now he is
mostly remembered for the Monica
Lewinsky investigation but a lot of his
investigation actually was into
Clinton's business dealings that's how
thing got started with whitewater now
you've probably heard many reports and
commentary today talking about how
robert muller has has nailed so many
people in the Trump circle that this is
already this investigation is already a
big success well he would have a long
way to go to match Kenneth Starr who got
15 convictions not indictments 15
convictions or guilty pleas including
gem and Susan mcdougal who were the
president's business partners in the
whitewater venture webster hubbell who
was the clinton's very close friend and
a top Justice Department official and
gem guy Tucker who at the time was the
sitting governor of Arkansas this is not
nothing it was a big deal but the
Clinton scandal I wanted to look at
tonight and the one night I think tells
us something about today is the Clinton
scandal that did not get an Independent
Counsel in the 1990s a hostile foreign
power meddled in our presidential
election there were serious questions
about whether one party's candidate the
beneficiary was complicit in that
meddling or at least look the other way
while it was going on the candidate
fiercely resisted the appointment of an
independent counsel to investigate he
won and finally with only moderate tepid
media interest it all faded away the
country of course doing the meddling was
China and the presidential candidate was
Bill Clinton who was already in the
White House and seeking re-election in
1996 now if you look back on the press
accounts from this era it is striking
how brazen the players were as they went
about the task of funneling Chinese and
other foreign donations into the Clinton
campaign I mean it's just amazing in
light of the attention that is giving
given to Russian influence in the 2016
election how
was going on in 1996 now the names have
mostly been forgotten
anybody remember charlie tree okay John
Wong Johnny Chung I see a couple of
hands back there
the names are forgotten but the record
remains so I'm gonna talk about just a
little of what was going on
Johnny Chung born in Taiwan US citizen
prolific Democratic fundraiser between
1994 and 1996 he gave 366 thousand
dollars to the Democratic National
Committee and visited the Clinton White
House more than 50 times in 1995
Johnny Chung gave a $50,000 check to the
first lady's chief of staff at an event
on the White House grounds just walked
up gave it to her
and was later asked about this and his
memorable explanation was quote I see
the White House is like a subway you
have to put in coins to open the gates
for New Yorkers in the audience that's
in the prefetch ardh era but in 99 1999
Johnny Chung testified before a House
committee and he said that a few years
earlier during the election campaign 19
1996 he met with the head of Chinese
military intelligence in the basement of
a restaurant in Hong Kong and that top
Chinese spy said this we really like
your president we hope to see him
reelected I will give you three hundred
thousand US dollars you can give it to
the president and the Democratic Party
I'm gonna read you something from the
Los Angeles Times which did good job
reporting on this back in the 90s
Chung's testimony has provided
investigators the first direct link
between a senior Chinese government
official and illicit foreign
contributions that were funneled into
Clinton's 1996 re-election effort it is
the strongest evidence that the highest
levels of the Chinese government sought
to influence the u.s. election process
does any of that sound familiar
with what is going on today
now in the great tradition of operators
Johnny Chun ended up taking a lot of
money for himself but some of that money
from Chinese military intelligence that
would be the People's Liberation Army
made its way into the Clinton campaign
and into other Democratic efforts Chung
also testified that he had also
contributed money that came from another
officer in the People's Liberation Army
and from the son of China's top military
commander he pleaded guilty that is
Chung pleaded guilty to bank fraud tax
evasion and conspiracy and was sentenced
to probation then there was Charlie tree
who raised 1.2 million dollars in
federal money
excuse me foreign money for the Clinton
Legal Defense Fund in March 1996 during
the campaign he shows up at the Clinton
defense fund office in Washington he has
four hundred and sixty thousand dollars
in money orders they are sequentially
numbered and filled out with the same
handwriting nothing suspicious there he
also visited the White House 22 times
and pleaded guilty to violating federal
election law and was sentenced to
probation finally there was John Wong
the Democratic Party fundraiser raised
more than 1.5 million from illegal
foreign sources visited the White House
78 times he was an agent for an in the
Indonesian businessman whose name was
James riadi a Senate committee found
that riadi had a long-term relationship
with Chinese intelligence john wong
pleaded excuse me riadi pleaded guilty
to campaign finance violations and was
sentenced to probation
as all this news came out in the year
after the election I know that this
didn't come out until Clinton was safely
re-elected there were calls for an
independent counsel to investigate the
law was still in effect the Attorney
General at the time Janet Reno
steadfastly refused the Justice
Department doubled nothing got done the
investigation never reached the level it
would have would have had an Independent
Counsel been appointed Republicans
complained and complained and complained
but Reno never gave in the scandal was
news at the time I'm sure many of you
remember it some print outlets like the
LA Times did a good job in uncovering it
but it's received far less coverage on
television several news outlets
basically ignored it
you can watch any given hour at least
without a hurricane on CNN or MSNBC
especially and here hours and hours in
hours of conversation about Trump and
Russia this not so much the rhetoric too
was restrained I recently did a nexus
search searching various databases to
see if anyone had suggested that
President Clinton was guilty of treason
because of taking all this money from
the People's Liberation Army and no
people didn't do that and that's a good
thing so that was the Clinton foreign
influence scandal the one that did not
get an independent counsel compared to
today to the public discussion of Trump
in Russia and I will leave it to you as
to whether you think coverage of Trump
and Russia has been as restrained and
cautious as it was in 1996 seven eight
and nine but I will talk about something
about the Trump Russia affair that I
think is really important and it does
tell us something in real contrast to
the Clintons aren't foreign influence
scandal
that was because I think we might be in
new territory with this Trump Russia
matter and that is because of the condom
the United States intelligence and law
enforcement agencies now a few months
ago I took part in a debate in New York
City and the debate was does the Russia
investigation endanger the rule of law
and I was on the side that argued yes I
had a partner also arguing yes and that
was Alan Dershowitz now a few months ago
I would not have guessed that I would
have appeared with professor Dershowitz
discussing a weighty topic in a comedy
club in Greenwich Village but those are
the times we live in
so one of the things I said is that if
by endanger the rule of law you mean
does it destroy our legal order threaten
our democracy and I think no I don't
think does I don't think the Trump
Russia investigation does that but if
you think it means involves our nation's
most powerful law enforcement and
intelligence agencies in reckless
political conduct that undermines our
system of elections and the orderly
transfer of power then yes I think it
does in fact endanger the rule of law
and I think there are two incidents that
we need to look at more closely that
point to the danger of overzealous
investigators the first is that the
Justice Department used a law called the
Logan Act which bars private Americans
from conducting foreign policy as a
pretense to pursue an investigation
against the incoming Trump team now for
those of you who haven't studied this
the Logan Act was passed in 1799 and has
never been used to successfully
prosecute anybody no one has even tried
since the 19th century it's by any
practical measure dead and you can look
up the legal concept of desuetude and
you'll see what the Logan Act is which
is it's dead if you if you pass a law
and you don't enforce it for 200 years
you can't just start
and yet in the summer of 2016 during the
campaign some prominent Democrats began
accusing Trump of violating the Logan
Act they said remember that time when
Trump said Russia if you're listening
let's see those emails those Hillary
Clinton deleted emails some Democrats
called for hearings of that and after
the election they were stunned they were
angry and they were watching Trump
prepare to undo many of Barack Obama's
policies and some of them turn to the
Logan Act one democratic representative
introduced the one president at a time
act of 2016 which would specifically
subject presidents elect to the Logan
Act I don't know who that could have
been about or true presidents elect to
the Logan Act John Conyers who was then
the top Democrat on the House Judiciary
Committee asked the Justice Department
to investigate Trump for possibly
violating the Logan Act now all of that
was just political posturing that is not
a threat to the rule of law but
unbeknownst to the public the Obama
Justice Department was using the Logan
act as a pretext to take action against
the incoming administration when
intelligence intercept picked up Michael
Flynn who is the new national security
adviser talking to the Russian
ambassador in December of 2016 that is
during the transition the Obama Justice
Department saw this as a possible
violation of the Logan Act which it
certainly wasn't because many foreign
policy experts saw absolutely nothing
wrong with the income nation' incoming
national security adviser talking to a
foreign official nevertheless four days
into the Trump administration on January
24th 2017 Sally Yates who is the
holdover Obama official leading the
Justice Department she's the acting
Attorney General she sent agents to the
White House to question Flynn ostensibly
on the suspicion that he violated the
Logan Act
and it was that interview that
ultimately resulted in Flynn pleading
guilty of one count of lying to the FBI
the bottom line with that is that the
Flynn saga which is at the very heart of
the Trump Russia investigation appears
to have hinged on a trumped-up suspicion
that an incoming not yet in office
administration had broken a
centuries-old law that had never been
prosecuted before when in fact the new
administration's real transgression was
to make it clear it was going to
overturn Barack Obama's policies now the
second incident that I think points to
the dangers of overzealous investigation
is the FBI's use of the Trump dossier I
hope you've all heard of the Trump
dossier
it's the Clinton campaign Oppo research
product the FBI used it as part of its
counterintelligence investigation into
the Trump campaign we know that to
compile the dossier a democratic law
firm hired the opposition research group
fusion GPS who then hired Christopher
Steele that former British spy who paid
a number of Russian collectors he called
them collectors who then talked to other
Russians who provided gossip allegedly
about Trump most spectacular gossip in
that dossier of course was the
description of Trump in a Moscow hotel
room in 2013 watching as prostitutes
carried out a kinky sex scene so Steele
takes this material to the FBI and in a
development that I think is still
astonishing the bureau agrees to pay
Steele to keep doing the work keep
gathering dirt on Trump this is at the
height of the 2016 campaign even though
this deal falls through the FBI still
incorporates the dossier into its Trump
Russian investigation we all know how
they used it to get a wiretap warrant on
Carter page but in the transition one of
the more stunning scenes of the whole
Trump era to
early January 2017 Trump is
president-elect the intelligence Chiefs
James Comey John Brennan Mike Rogers
James clapper they traveled to Trump
Tower to brief the president-elect on
their report about Russian efforts to
interfere with the 2016 campaign which
are real really happened after the
briefing they have devised a plan by
which three of them will leave and James
Comey will stay one-on-one with Trump
and Trump tells once they're alone Trump
tells Comey about the Moscow sex scene
we had earlier earlier had reports that
said Trump told excuse me comb he told
Trump about the whole dossier didn't
happen Comey later said now we just
talked about the hotel thing so he
imagined this the very first time the
incoming president met the FBI director
face-to-face the FBI's message was we
know about you and those hookers in
Russia which is it's kind of astonishing
it's a very j edgar hoover ich there's a
book called russian roulette' authors
are david korn and michael izikoff they
report that Trump immediately felt the
FBI was blackmailing him Trump had seen
this sort of thing before they wrote
certainly is mentor
Roy Cohn knew how this worked so did
commis famous predecessor j edgar Hoover
who quietly let it be known to
politicians that he possessed
information that could destroy their
careers how could Trump think otherwise
when he gets this briefing amazingly
enough the briefing of Trump soon leaks
to the media and it was the fact that
top officials had seen fit to brief the
incoming president about the dossier
that made this a story they legitimized
it and turned it into a story by having
this briefing within hours the website
BuzzFeed published a whole dossier on
the Internet voila it's all out in
public
remember that Charles Schumer the
Democratic leader in the Senate said as
this was happening he said you take on
the intelligence community they have six
ways from Sunday of getting back at you
so with the Logan Act Obama holdovers
used a dead law as a pretense to push
the Trump investigation with the dossier
they used unverified Oppo research not
only to investigate the Trump campaign
but to execute a clever maneuver to make
it all public and this was all done by
the nation's top law enforcement and
intelligence officials targeting a new
president that is troubling and so if
you look at the Clinton foreign
influence campaign and you look at the
Trump foreign influence investigation
you see very very different things you
see sluggish law enforcement in one you
see overzealous law enforcement and the
other you see a largely uninterested
media and one and you see a fixated
media in the other so those are bookends
of political scandal in Washington for
the last twenty years although there are
many many others and I would be happy to
take your questions on any of those or
any other subject you might want to
bring up but thank you very much for
inviting me this evening
you